when the mercury drops below freezing
motorists have to set their alarm clocks
a little earlier they have a lot to do
before they get behind the wheel but
many people forget then things can get
pretty hectic as Cornelia boss knows all
too well she has to get up early for
work she explains and she's usually in a
hurry but on winter morning she often
gets to the car only to find the
windshield iced over the best thing to
do is cover the windshield with
thermofoil the evening before it only
costs a few euros and it saves valuable
time scraping ice off the car windows it
also prevents frozen windscreen wipers
from breaking another tip is to jam
corks underneath them then the rubber
doesn't freeze to the windshield
car doors that are frozen and can't be
opened are another winter headache a
glycerin stick is the best bet here and
also only costs a few euros all you have
to do is apply it to the rubber
stripping to prevent freezing
snow and icy roads make driving
dangerous in winter but so does keeping
your coat on if it means you haven't
fastened your seat belt properly that's
why it's always best to take your coat
off if Cornelia keeps her snug winter
anorak on the belt is too loose and no
longer offers adequate protection an
airbag wouldn't be much use in the event
of a crash either the belt is securely
fastened if it's tight at the buckle
what happens if the car doesn't even
start then it's time to jump start it
it's easy enough attach one of the red
clips of the jumper cables to your
batteries plus terminal attach the other
red clip to the plus terminal in the
other car attached one of the black
clips to the minus terminal on the other
battery and attach the last black clip
to an unpainted metal surface on your
car that isn't near the battery on
Colonel Hyde Schneider from Germany's
automobile club the ABAC explains if you
connect to the minus pose to the dead
battery you risk igniting hydrogen gas
coming off it that's why you need to
connect the other black lamp to a piece
of grounded metal once the engines
running before you remove the jumper
cables switch on all the lights of the
car with the wig battery to avoid high
voltage building up otherwise the
electric system could end up damaged if
not actually ruined Dawkins is
responding and taking T done some defect
electronic fuel consumption file to
continue to electronic up with Kindle
it's also worth using anti freeze for
the windscreen wipers and radiator but
you might want to consult an expert
first about the exact amounts required
topping up the antifreeze solution in a
car's cooling system isn't as
straightforward as it sounds
if the solution stays on the top the
water can still freeze and damage the
engine block broke the spell to find
food ilysm once a car has been wit er
proved getting started in the morning
becomes a whole lot easier find positive
like Cornelia boss you might want to
leave some jobs up to the garage but
even the clueless can invest in a bottle
of antifreeze ultimately it'll save them
a lot of extra costs almost coastal
clean but safety is of course the first
priority